you
escaped from prison
five times so what uh what stands out to
you as the most difficult
or miraculous escape in the bunch
the most black miraculous was when i was
in the courtroom in spain i think i was
i was on the third floor of real high
and i ran across a courtroom handcuffed
kicked the window out
and i looked down and it was above the
palm trees i thought they might be a
power line or something i could grab on
as i went down
there was nothing and there was a car
parked a station wagon on the uh
jumped out i jumped out from 31 feet and
on top of that car
and it exploded in the street the
windshield went over three or four cars
it looked like snow going up and i
looked like donald duck with the thing
in handcuffs and i got out and just kept
running yeah i kept trying they ran me
down
and hit me in the back i still got a
dead spot in my back where the policeman
hit me with a shotgun
and they brought me back mario was there
they were saying
your husband is crazy that was
spectacular but i escaped from lubeck
maximum security prison
and i cut out of there and and got out
that was miraculous
germany what was what was that escape
like
i was airing out whether it was going to
uh extradite me back to the united
states where i still had all these
charges in 25 years special parole
and uh i was cleaning the uh
lawyer's visiting room and on it was uh
bars that looked like a piano notes or
this way
to make it pretty but there was a little
bit so i got a rope from a guy
where they made boats in there and i
i had 20 minutes so i went in there and
i wrapped it around and i put a broom
handle in it that was cut off and
wrapped it around
until it pulled the bars together on
that side and then i pulled them
together on the other side but that only
put me in
inside the prison yard where the uh
soccer equipment was kept but they were
putting new windows on one side of the
prison and they had it scaffolded up to
the fourth floor
so there was a little recess there and
there was guard towers every
100 feet or so i mean they would shoot
and kill you
so i got behind that uh and climbed up
holding to the bricks on one hand and
the scaffolding on the other
and went to the roof i lost my shirt and
most of my clothes going through the
window i got all the skin off of me i
thought it was going to die
and i was trying to go sideways like
this and finally i got a grip
and the bars let me through and took all
the skin off of me
so i got up on that roof and i have
asthma and i just lay there trying to
catch my breath
didn't bring my inhaler so
with blood everywhere oh i was bloody
yes and so i got down to the end
and on the end the reason i did it they
would put it they was putting a new wall
again
again around the prison to make it
larger
and they had taken all the wire off
above the sally port
where they could join the two walls
together and i saw that when i came up
and there was a guard a half of a
like a dome sticking out of that brick
building where there's a guard there
with a gun and he'd kill you
i mean he was made they were surely
trained to kill you and we had some bad
people in that place
so i lay up a one one floor above it and
i saw a guard and his wife come with a
double umbrella
which is pouring down the rain here i am
without a shirt on bloody
and he had a little boy she had a little
boy with him under that double umbrella
and i knew him and when he come and she
started back from the sally port
i hit the top of that guard tower bam
with both feet and i jumped i guess it's
three more floors i jumped there was a
pile of sand
like a cone where they were digging it
there and i hit that
and my feet buried up to the knees but i
didn't fall
and i ran straight towards her so he
couldn't shoot me and then i went around
some bushes and went downhill
and then i heard bam bam bam bam blam
behind me and i looked and that food
woman was in a big old car
and she was knocking down the parking
meters behind me she was trying to run
over me
and i ran behind the car oh wow and she
tore the fender off of her car
trying and yelling yeah yeah yapping a
terrible evil looking face at me
screaming at me
and the sirens going off in the prison
and there was a fence there a wall and i
jumped up on it to jump over and it was
had glass in bed and i cut my hands and
my arms all up getting over that
and i hit the ground on the other side
and it was like it was that much milk
where some farmer had dug it
i dug in there and mari had slipped me
200 in the prison
and i had that in my shoe and i lost my
shoes in that mud but anyway i got out
there and got to holland
really heck of a story how i did that
you